as president Trump prepares for his
summit with North Korean leader Kim
jong-un Fox News anchor Bret Baier is
revisiting another historic meeting
involving a Republican president 30
years ago this month President Ronald
Reagan went to Moscow for a Cold War
summit with Soviet leader Mikhail
Gorbachev during that visit President
Reagan spoke to students at Moscow State
University he was optimistic about the
possibility of freedom and democracy in
Russia in this Moscow spring this may
1988 we may be allowed that hope that
freedom like the fresh green sapling
planted over Tolstoy his grave will
blossom forth at last in the rich
fertile soil of Europe people and
culture in his new book bear calls that
speech a dramatic and significant event
at the end of Reagan's presidency the
book is titled three days in Moscow
Ronald Reagan in the fall of the Soviet
empire Bret Baier welcome back thanks
for havin graduations good morning the
New York Times said of this speech it
may have been ronald reagan's finest
oratorical hour he had a lot of fine
oratorical hours why this one because he
was speaking in the heart of communism
in Moscow to students young people about
the West and saying why the West is the
way that they should turn it was a
moment at the end of these four summits
between Mikhail Gorbachev and Reagan at
which he was trying to reach out saying
what what the Soviet Union could be and
it was overlooked really at the time
despite the New York Times write-up as
far as its significance looking back now
that was a big moment did you talk about
the relationship between these two men
Brett that's what I thought was so
interesting Reagan and Gorbachev Reagan
and Gorbachev that they became Mikhail
and Ron that they really genuinely
seemed to like each other despite their
differences and at some times
name-calling right I mean some of these
summits got heated they walked away from
the table both of them waving fingers
waving figures at each other's faces but
they had this relationship that
developed where they trusted each other
and they knew they when they got to the
one point they would step away but they
also had a friendship that developed
over the years you talk about let me
just go through this right you have
Geneva in in 1985 Reykjavik 86
Washington and 80s
in Moscow in in in 88 describe how his
rhetoric changed as well his public
rhetoric so Reagan really all the way
back to when he was the president the
Screen Actors Guild in Hollywood
fighting communism their always talked
aggressively about communism and how it
would not work and he believed
eventually in speeches as president
there would be on the ash heap of
history and the Soviet Union was the
evil empire and it would be really
aggressive the things he said in fact
Nancy Reagan even said hey listened dial
it back a little bit but that enabled
him when Mikhail Gorbachev came to the
front to say this is a guy I can work
with you know when you go back to those
radio speeches he used to gave this is
the thing he thought about his entire
adult life even the way before he
thought about running for president the
relationship between capitalism and
communism freedom and oppression this
was in a sense his in his bones so he
can make those decisions briefing books
are important but he could make those
decisions on the fly with Gorbachev and
that's what Secretary of State George
Shultz said was so amazing about Reagan
is that it was his inherent belief that
communism was never going to work that
that enabled him to get into these
meetings in summits and believe he had
the upper hand even if in negotiating he
may not have one of the things he's
obviously an icon of the conservative
movement but when he first started
meeting with Gorbachev a lot of
conservatives thought he's gonna take
you he's gonna upstage you he's gonna
you know why are you doing this he got a
lot of grief from the right because
remember Mikhail Gorbachev was a was a
rock star he was this young up-and-comer
he was being received by the world as
someone who was really great at
explaining things and conservatives were
worried he was going to give up the
store Reagan and that that meeting in
Reykjavik when he comes out and he's
wearing a suit and he walks to meet
Gorbachev and Gorbachev pulls up and
he's wearing a winter coat and a scarf
and a hat the image was actually the
older Reagan looked younger and the
Gorbachev look huddled and like an old
native like that I love the part in the
book you made people don't the point you
make people don't make wars government
does and when people are free to choose
they will always choose peace it sure
does seem like there are some lessons
for us in that big time and as you look
now you know fast forward the last
chapter to the books of
last word and it looks at the threats
that we face and obviously I didn't know
that they were going to be a there's
going to be a summit in Singapore a
timing for nothing to do with it but it
actually is on June 12th which June 12
1987 is the day of the Berlin speech at
Brandenburg Gate where Reagan says tear
down this wall a line that everybody
wanted him to take out in the White
House and the State Department and he
put back in but what would learn about
it I talked to secretary Shultz in a
long interview who by the way is a
national treasure I want to see 93 yeah
and he remembers meetings like they were
yesterday and I just want to read a
quote what he said about the negotiating
of Reagan his principles number one be
realistic number two be strong not just
military strength economic strength but
then more than that have strength of
purpose then number three figure out
what it is you want don't start thinking
about what other people want because
you'll be negotiating with yourself just
what you want then when you have all
that straight sit down and negotiate
then you've got the hand to play now
this is secretary Shultz who was in
those rooms one of the only people in
those rooms and you know there might be
some lessons to be learned in summits to
come sending it over to anybody you know
and as a leader be open to lessons from
other people of course there you go so
it's fascinating
but they're always nice yeah table very
much probably so it's the name of the
book Nora three days in Moscow it goes
on sale win now right now and when we
say it's a very good read congrats to
you thank you it's also available as a
young readers edition